ask this because every time we watch
aaron rodgers play
we're blown away and it's just certain
moments throughout the game that you
just go man how did he just do that what
amazes you most watching him play for
hey chris the crazy thing about when i
watch aaron rodgers it trips me out
because he sees everything and he gets
the ball out of his hands so quickly so
he makes it so difficult for a defense
to try to blitz him to try to disguise
coverage and it's just so tough and
every time i see aaron rodgers playing
this is the only quarterback that i've
said this about every time i see aaron
rodgers play i say wow he does something
incredible i can't believe in his
relationship with devante adams it's
that extra sensory perception that esp
that telepathic
i just googled it before the broadcast
but they got that telepathic
communication route what makes that
connection so unique well the fans sit
back and they see the catches they see
the numbers they see the touchdowns but
they don't understand all the work that
goes on behind the scenes practice the
the meetings walkthroughs and things and
just the casual conversations passing
each other in the locker room and you've
knocked off a whole bunch of great wide
receiver quarterback combinations how
would you try to defend that duo we get
to some of these big games in the
playoffs well we talk about double
coverage and even the minnesota vikings
tried to double cover them on the first
play and he's still completed i would
take my number one corner and my number
one safety double team him and force
aaron rodgers to go elsewhere with the
ball you cannot allow devante adams to
have a big game like he had tonight well
now they get this guy aj dillon right
you got dylan who's coming out of the
backfield big power back out of boston
college loves his applesauce he'll be
joining us here in just a second we'll
ask him about all of the above but what
element has he brought specifically for
cold weather football which is coming
their way well number one depth you know
we know aaron aaron jones
why are these people calling my name
they're not cold at all rod i don't see
one cold person they'll be here till 3
a.m if they let them so what's the
question again aj dylan what's he
brought to this packers toughness just
depth i mean you look think about 250
pounds in this weather and we saw in the
fourth quarter in the third quarter when
they get a comfortable lead now they can
lean on him they can run the football
wear defense down and that's exactly
what happened today and then you got
coach lefleur who's sort of given just
stability to this whole operation and it
wasn't always rose's his relationship
with aaron rodgers but what does that
blossom into that relationship it's it's
it's beautiful because he knows and he
understands aaron rodgers he understands
that unique personality and he's a guy
that's getting the most out of aaron
rodgers so if i'm aaron rodgers there's
no way i'm leaving the green bay packers
everything is set up perfectly for you
you got a really good offensive line
you're getting a bunch of guys back on
defense your defense is going to
continue to grow and get better and of
course you got the best wide receiver in
all of football in devonta adams what do
you think about david bachari coming
back sedaria smith coming back jair
alexander coming back really three of
their best players you look outside of
aaron rodgers what will that infusion of
talent do come play off time man let me
tell you it's going to give them a boost
because you know at times you see and
you kind of see a leaky
packers defense and you start to see
well maybe they're a little tight but
then you get this level of talent
enthusiasm to come in it's going to be
big for them energy wise hey chris sims
when you think about the whole nfc all
these teams now having to come into
lambeau who do you see that can come
beat this group with the way they're
playing down the home stretch yeah no
it's going to take a special performance
so again listen i'm not going to count
out tampa bay and tom brady certainly
not right i mean you guys we've seen
we've been there done that and of course
he's used to the cold weather coming
from new england hey the dallas cowboys
i'm still going to put them in the mix
there to be one of those teams you know
again just too many great physical
football players on both sides of the
ball but
i i mean the list is it's short it
really is i would probably put the 49ers
in that category maybe to a degree
but to go up to green bay rogers knows
this i've had these conversations with
him he knows they're a different team up
there in january when they when the
elements are in their favor 10 degrees
he knows he can still throw laser beams
all over the field it doesn't matter if
it's windy or cold so whoever does come
up there they're going to have their
hands full and you're going to have to
play a perfect game as far as execution
is concerned i don't know if you guys
heard me in the opening but that's the
one thing i'm amazed by by this packers
team they remind me a lot of like the
patriots teams rodney played on doesn't
always just go wow wow wow but they
never miss up mess the game up they
execute in all phases of the football
game and that's where they're really
impressive hey chris i got to ask you
again again did you say the san
francisco 49ers i heard that you believe
they can come up here and beat the green
bay packers in this weather i'm gonna
put them in a short like i don't feel as
confident about maybe them as tampa or
dallas but the way they run the football
and with shanahan and his ability to
come up with game plan plays make the
game easy on the quarterback and then
their defense being a top 10 defense i
am rodney i'm going to put them in that
i know i'm probably in the minority in
that conversation but uh i like a lot of
the things i see into that 49er team
the only thing that i was kind of
hesitant on is because jimmy g he has
that injured hand right yeah it's cold
up here and these guys are physical they
get after the quarterback i'm gonna have
to disagree with you a little bit on
that one
i do agree with you on tampa bay tampa
bay could definitely come up in here and
play well and i still believe in the
dallas cowboys but you think about tampa
bay they've really been weakened chris
scott went out of the lineup we saw what
happened with antonio brown today as
well mike evans been battling a
hamstring
today talking about what did you see
from time after that game tom was
dejected he was dejected because he put
so much effort and time in trying to
develop and trying to help antonio brown
out and for him to be so selfish like
that and the kid needs help that's what
tom's spot on but i mean tom is
frustrated yeah and here in green bay
what's what has everybody so excited
those championship expectations just
continue to rise it's because of this
defense so when you watch this green bay
defense on the field rachel douglas a
mid-season pickup they had what is it
that catches your eye about that d you
know what they have a lot of a lot of
great fantastic players i mean start
start up front with kenny clark i mean
the guy's just been absolutely
dominating the interior of the defense
they try to double team this kid they
try to double team them and he breaks
the tackles and then you get that
pressure from the outsides of darius
smith you get rashaan gary and then you
get zadarius smith coming back during
the playoffs they're going to be very
tough to deal with and we haven't even
talked about zaire alexander the all-pro
cornerback that just gives them more
depth depth at the most important place
i'm a pro as much as these fans are
yelling my name i'm still focused
this might be the most lively group of
fans that we have for a post game show
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports